E aí
[Música]
Oi boa tarde a todos só a ter em atenção
antes de começarmos que estava a fazer
uma pequena introdução continuar também
a tradição Começamos hoje de manhã
de vamos lá onde é que crescemos vivo De
que parte é que somos aqui de Alcobaça
eu sou do carrascal que se também
dividir dentro carrascal e a urbanização
quinta de Almeida aqui em Alcobaça em
frente ao Intermarché achei uma opinião
interessante falarmos disso de manhã
mencionamos de onde é que nós somos e o
que como é que estamos aqui hoje só
fazer aqui um reparamos começamos isso
oficialmente disseram que era doutorado
mas eu estou adulterar é só atenção de
quem ainda o processo vai doer
e também antes começarmos a ser bateram
Palmas mas atenção porque não se
entusiasme muito porque eu venho aqui
para você trazer hoje não irá deixar
muitos voz satisfeitos tanto vamos
começar e depois no final podemos falar
sobre a nossa situação e como estamos de
pés assentes no planeta
bom então os limites da sustentabilidade
no título como este que seguramente
denuncia o Tom desta apresentação é
verdade eu venho aqui hoje partilhar
convosco não irá certamente tranquilizar
muitos de vós mas poderá tal como fez
comigo libertar vos de algumas das
ilusões relativamente a relação da nossa
espécie com esse planeta
a reforma a Navegar neste tópico
complexo e crítico permitam parte a
primeira convosco uma história atrás de
mim podem ver a imagem de um lado
Ecológico e uma das minhas grandes
paixões no dia como qualquer outro
entrei para dentro deste lado para
limpar os filtros só que tinha estado a
ler ao sol e colocar protetor solar
quando eu percebi um foco de poluição
Diz que estava se rapidamente em todas
as direções e o rei foi que esta nova
perturbação pudesse ultrapassar a
capacidade adaptativa desde pequeno
ecossistema
E foi neste momento que percebi que este
pequeno lado funcionava como uma réplica
do nosso planeta do limitado e
profundamente interligado se não tivesse
saído que me viram a substância da pele
e retirado novamente presente lá com um
balde poderia ter desencadeado um
processo que levaria ao colapso de toda
esta ecossistema
O Pedro é pensar que a pequena dimensão
deste Lago o torna especialmente
vulnerável a like o nosso planeta sempre
pelo contrário tão vasto não poderá ser
afetado a mesma forma por perturbações
e esta análise está correta Mas requer
algumas ressalvas
devido à dimensão do sistemas
planetários a sua complexidade e o facto
de se encontram tão profundamente
interligados não é possível decidir com
toda a certeza onde uma perturbação num
destes temas poderá causar ondas no
outro sistema de um exemplo com
aquecimento gradual da atmosfera e dos
oceanos devido ao aquecimento global
aquele as férias está a sofrer no
processo também com o degelo dos
icebergs
o problema intensifica-se quando
percebemos que o desaparecimento desses
iceberg diz diminui o albedo natural da
terra ou seja a sua capacidade para
refletir a radiação de volta para o
espaço o que acontece é que a terra e
tem mais desta radiação solar aquece no
processo e acelera um processo de degelo
naquilo a que chamamos um loop de
feedback positivo
reparem só na diferença entre as duas
superfícies sabendo que hoje ele tem o
albedo muito superior e que o planeta é
essencial com a crescente atividade
humana
Ah mas isso é só um dos inúmeros
exemplos que conhecemos de
interdependências entre os temas do
planeta outra característica que
mencionei que se distinguia do meu Lago
era a própria dimensão destes sistemas
infelizmente esses tem conspirado contra
nós por favor ser uma ilusão de infinito
tudo e vi uma resiliência indisputável é
certamente mais fácil ignoramos os
limites do nosso planeta e legitimar
Mussum paradigma de crescimento
continuado quanto usar em fugir das
feito longe da nossa vista
mas por exemplo se eu decidi começar a
utilizar a água do meu lado para
agricultura rapidamente do teria efeitos
da estação e Continuará a fazê-lo
invariavelmente causaria o seu colapso
e como tal a vastidão do nosso planeta
assim com uma enorme obstáculo a psique
de uma espécie onde a maior parte da sua
história e do seu impacto foi ao nível
local e por vezes Regional mas nunca
Global
esta última transição porque os quer
falar de seguida façamos Uma Breve
Viagem ao Passado de forma entendemos
onde é que a relação da nossa espécie
com este planeta mais se alterou
a ser impossível falar desta relação sem
estudarmos evolução da população humana
neste planeta olhamos para este gráfico
se vemos que durante a maior parte da
nossa história pelo menos neste gráfico
um período de 12 mil anos a nossa
população permaneceu com nível muito
embaixo algumas dezenas de milhões e que
o ritmo de aceleração era praticamente
negligenciável é somente após a
Revolução Industrial que começamos a ver
o ritmo a acelerar sendo que depois da
segunda guerra mundial adquiriu este
crescimento abrupto
dá para perceber em escala de mudança
considere que em 1933 quando o meu avô
nasceu e que ainda está vivo a população
mundial tinha acabado atingir o segundo
melhor do ML
nós estamos hoje perto quadriplicar com
7.9 milhões de humanos em 2021
e infelizmente as projeções demográficas
províncias acontecimento conte no pelo
menos até o final do século em vários
milhares de milhões de pessoas
adicionais no planeta
considerem também essa parte é
importante queria de Janeiro 2020 um
período de mais ou menos 18 meses que o
novo coronavírus causou a morte de pelo
menos 4 milhões de pessoas oficiais no
entanto no mesmo período de tempo a
população humana expandiu-se em cerca de
120 milhões de pessoas e isto é
contabilizar já com Óbidos
Com estes números parecem surreais mas
seguem uma tendência que já acontece há
muitos anos
e já podemos então perceber que nos
últimos 70 anos mais ou menos que a
população cresceu a um ritmo sem
precedentes no entanto não foi somente
esta a passar por este
crescimento econômico a economia Global
uma boa forma de contemplarmos o
conjunto de todas as atividades humanas
passou por um processo tão semelhante
que os gráficos parecem idênticos
uma das principais razões que levam a
este crescimento bruto é o fato que os
seres humanos modernos estão a consumir
em média muito mais recursos do que os
nossos antepassados ao mesmo tempo que a
carga de consumidores aumentou de uma
forma nova lá como os trem anterior
antigamente
e
esses dois gráficos da população e da
economia mostra o também muito
interessante este período de crescimento
após a Segunda Guerra Mundial de veio a
ser denominado como a grande aceleração
e não existem falta de exemplos de como
o crescimento destes dois fatores veio
também a evidenciar por exemplo
tendências socioeconómicas com maiores
necessidades de energia de água produção
alimentar instalação de barragens
produção de papel turismo
infraestruturas entre muitas outras
tendências
é uma que certamente não pode ser
ignorada é o peso da pegada Material
necessário para sustentar a atual
civilização Industrial que em 2020
ultrapassou o limite que nos deveria
fazer refletir o peso esta pegada
material e agora se superior a toda a
biomassa do planeta é isso que se vê
neste ponto intercessão
e ao mesmo tempo a expansão da economia
como da população Vieram também a tornar
mais Evidente outros problemas
ambientais tais como emissão de gases
efeito estufa como o dióxido de carbono
eo metano que são dos principais
responsáveis pelo aquecimento global ao
mesmo tempo que estes gases também
intensificam a acidificação dos oceanos
e o aumento das temperaturas
Eu lamento destas duas destes dois
fatores está também ligado a maiores
capturas de peixe
maiores necessidades de utilização de
fertilizantes na agricultura a
desflorestação e claro a conversão de
zonas naturais para fins humanos EA
perda continuar de espécies
e o que é evidente que estes gráficos
claramente não podem demonstrar todas as
formas com uma nossa espécie está por
várias planeta no entanto eles
demonstram aqui uma coisa muito
importante
este período de crescimento ou a estudar
este fenómeno não parece ter nenhum
limite seja o que sustentam a pergunta
importante até quando poderá este regime
de crescimento contínuo procurar e onde
é que nos deparamos com os limites nossa
própria sustentabilidade
a este luxo focos do trabalho do centro
de violência de Estocolmo que apresenta
aqui onde os autores argumentam que a
humanidade já ultrapassou uma zona de
elevado risco a laranja pelo menos dois
limites planetários
a integralidade a biosfera e os fluxos
biogeoquímicos através principalmente do
uso de fertilizantes como fosfato e
Nitrato na agricultura
nós estamos ao mesmo tempo numa zona de
aumento de risco amarelo de outros dois
limites planetários as alterações
climáticas EA conversão das zonas
naturais para fins humanos e os outros
limites que são aqui incluídos ou
permanecem por quantificar aos autores
argumentam que este ainda se encontram
numa zona de segurança a verde tanto
quanto sabemos
é o outro limite que não deve ser
ignorado é totalidade da Pegada
Ecológica global que não temos qualquer
dúvida que se encontra no estado
sobrecarga já há várias décadas Ou seja
que ultrapassamos o limite
a única razão pela qual continuamos a
operar mesmo no paradigma da
sustentabilidade é porque estamos a
transformar a biosfera no monopólio de
supremacia para uma só espécie e estamos
a transformar num Recreio enquanto
tiramos as outras espécies de acesso
esta biosfera
eu comprei agora é uma breve lista de
artigos científicos que demonstram que
temos andado a subestimar as
consequências deste monopólio na
biosfera
o bolo é e Tu disseste aponta para uma
conclusão muito simples as coisas estão
bem pior do que mesmo a ciência
conseguiu perder alguns anos atrás agora
vejamos o que nos diz e os artigos de
gelo ou correr mais rápido que era
calculado ao mesmo tempo que os níveis
do mar subiram mais do que era projetado
e os oceanos estão retirar menos calor
da atmosfera do que era expectável
e simultaneamente as plantas estão
retirar o menos dióxido de carbono da
atmosfera do ter também projetado e as
florestas tropicais que foram
transformadas em plantações para fins
humanos têm um potencial de sequestro de
carbono muito abaixo do que era esperado
e as mortes por poluição atmosférica São
Thomé do dobro do que era assumido EA
contribuição do setor aéreo para esta
poluição e para o aquecimento global
continua a ser absolutamente subestimada
dos mais um exemplo se considerarmos
toda a história da humanidade para
cálculos de aquecimento global investir
somente o período pós-industrial quando
geralmente é feito temos uma
contribuição que nos coloca muito mais
perto dos dois graus centígrados
estipuladas No acordo de Paris vocês
podem perguntar porque é que não
consideramos esta contribuição eu
pergunto no mesmo certamente que antes
da Revolução Industrial que a nossa
espécie não vive em perfeito equilíbrio
com o planeta está se encontrar ou
teríamos sociedades no passado que por
alterarem e sobrecarregar e os seus mais
envolventes levaram em alguns dos casos
a diminuição da sua resiliência perante
novas adversidades em outros casos ao
seu próprio Pilatos
A Minha tese doutoramento debruçar-se
exatamente na ponte entre os atuais
limites tentabilidade como sociedades do
passado com uma fração dos níveis
modernos de população e da economia
conseguiram mesmo assim sobrecarregar os
seus ambientes ao ponto de alguns dos
casos colocarem e não a falta de
exemplos de sociedades que encaixem
nessa definição
os acadianos na Mesopotâmia há 4.000
anos os maias e as sociedades o Sudoeste
americano
a ilha da Páscoa
o antigo reino egípcio
e os romanos os gregos entre outros mas
todos estes já foram implicados na
literatura científica em questões ou por
sobrecarga dos seus mais envolventes ou
por falta de resiliência perante
alterações climáticas e estes últimos
dois são paradigmáticos para nós aqui no
Mediterrâneo a degustação intensiva que
causaram no seu tempo levou uma
alteração tão profunda da paisagem que
ainda hoje em dia pensamos que esta era
a Ecologia da nossa zona
e ao mesmo tempo que os seus projetos
mineração Deixaram um legado de
toxicidade tão duradouro que hoje em dia
em sítios como o sul da Jordânia o solo
permanece tóxico
bom E com isso tudo já devem estar a
pensar bem este tipo não estava mesmo a
brincar com disso não tinha boas
notícias
Mas o que eu quero saber o que podemos
fazer para resolver isto antes disso mas
o gráfico esse gráfico mostrado muito
simples apesar de décadas de tratados
conferências e pelos a mudança as
concentrações de gases efeito estufa
neste caso CO2 não param de aumentar
porque
reverter esta tendência seria não só
necessário para a tanto o crescimento da
economia como da população mas sim de
contrair os mesmos É isso mesmo o nível
atual da nossa economia e da população
Nunca irão possibilitar uma permanência
sustentável neste planeta e eu sou meio
que eu estou a dizer bom e quando
pensamos que estamos estes dois fatores
são prognosticados para continuarem a
crescer no futuro até os limites
planetários o permitirem certamente que
estas concentrações de dióxido de
carbono não irão parar o problema é a
contração destes dois fatores da
população e da economia não tem um
mínimo apelo social o político que é que
está disposto a viver com menos
prosperidade o que geração anterior e a
deixar como legado aos seus filhos a
tendência o melhor ainda que é que está
disposto a providenciar incentivos
financeiros a pessoas ou casais que
decidem não ter esses vídeos exatamente
o contrário daquilo que ocorre quase por
todo mundo
E no entanto sem encontraremos esses
dois fatores Não interessa que promessas
ouvimos the grind ele se transições
justas agriculturas orgânicas renováveis
eletrificação da frota Automóvel São
desperdício alimentar a reciclagem a
lista é longa EA conclusão é simples
quando estas propostas são colocadas as
causas uma população que está a crescer
e quer consumir mais todas as tornam
insuficientes onde sustentáveis
como tal o que precisamos entre um novo
Imaginário e um Que contemplou ações com
impactos e tipos no e por isso o plano
alimentar
por tem sal zonas naturais e os seus
habitantes e não permitam que ilusões de
progresso as Trovão e juntas iniciativas
de conservação
Rio ao fim de frustação
de restauro e limpeza de ecossistemas
e a remoção de barragens também faz
Maravilhas esta ecossistemas
informe-se sobre economias estacionárias
e de crescimento e apoio em políticos
capazes de se defender
feijão também o fácil acesso a uma
educação de qualidade para rapazes e
raparigas em todo o mundo um acesso
também a metros contraceptivos o direita
que raparigas e mulheres decida o que
fazer com os seus corpos e claro não
tenho medo de apoiar o museu demográfico
e uma só criança olha para o exemplo
português de contração lenta e pensa em
que em vez de um cataclismo como
geralmente é referido que esta podia ser
uma resposta de sucesso que nunca
precisou de metros conhecidos e podia
ser publicada No resto do mundo
eu não posso buscar individual pelo
menos o que diz respeito às alterações
climáticas
foca-se nas atividades com maior impacto
à direita
o tempo em usar o vosso carro pessoal do
mínimo possível limitar o consumo
produtos de origem animal
como evitar andar de avião e claro é que
tem uma proporção dos profissional de
400 toneladas por ano limitem o consumo
o consumo desculpem
reduza o tamanho desejado vossa agregado
familiar não tem preferencialmente mais
do que uma criança e adotando sempre que
possível
G1 eu gostaria de finalizar dizendo que
se quiséssemos tudo o que acabei de
referir que tanto nós como outras
espécies neste planeta poderiam fugir
mutuamente durante muito tempo mas
simplesmente não sabem disso por tal
como vos disse os temas do planeta estão
a ser levados ao limite com
consequências desconhecidas e
subestimados ao mesmo tempo que agora
enfrentamos uma rede tão complexo de
problemas que ao tentarmos resolver um
estamos a criar problemas no outro
naquilo que eram os chamados o
equivalente
É mas o que eu sei é que enquanto
verificamos tanto o crescimento da
população como de Economia mas tivemos
uma cultura que quer níveis industriais
de energia e o consumo de recursos todos
os limites aqui referidos e outros serão
invariavelmente ultrapassados a nossa
espécie poderá sobreviver mas perderemos
a tranquilidade de climática que hoje em
dia desfrutamos ao mesmo tempo tempo
Ramos para atenção muitas outras
espécies enquanto uniformizantes este
planeta para os nossos efeitos
Estas são as consequências da Nossa
insustentabilidade obrigado
E aí
G1